[Music]
on this Monday night the investigation
into a midair scare what's been found
after that Alaska Airlines blowout a
loud boom or almost like a mini
explosion and we're warning signs
ignored Seeking Justice 4 years after
the Iranian military shot down a
passenger plane our grieving father says
Iran is trying to silence him maybe they
put me in jail or beat me or I have
nothing to lose plus the race back to
the Moon why the first American lunar
Landing attempt in decades is in
Jeopardy and an historic win at the
Golden Globes the actor putting
indigenous Pride into the
[Music]
spotlight global national with Donna FZ
good evening and thanks for joining us
as inspectors begin checking all the
Boeing 737 Max 9 Airplanes grounded in
the US there is new information about
Friday's dramatic midair blowout of a
section of an Alaska Airlines flight the
US national Transportation safety board
says Pilots reported pressurization
warning lights on three previous flights
of that same aircraft and tonight
Federal officials say an important clue
has been recovered in the backyard of a
Portland school teacher named Bob I'm
excited to announce that we found the
door
plug thank you
Bob a door plug is used to fill an
emergency exit on a plane that is not
needed on the flight it blew out shortly
after takeoff from Portland Friday night
there were no serious injuries but the
midair scare was terrifying and all 737
max9 planes in the US are grounded
tonight and this afternoon United
Airlines has confirmed inspections of
its max9 aircraft have turned up some
installation issues that include loose
bolts Jackson prco reports on what we
know in our top story tonight the gaping
hole in the Alaska Airlines plane may
offer investigators the best Clues as to
what happened to the Boeing 737 Max 9
shortly after takeoff the inflight
decompression was so powerful it ripped
open the cockpit door bent seats and
blew headrests out of the fuselage a
loud boom or almost like a mini
explosion incredibly there were no
serious injuries I found a phone sitting
on the side of the road that uh had
apparently Fallen 16 ,000 ft on the
ground debris including cell phones is
now turning up it was in airplane mode
with a travel confirmation and baggage
claim for Alaska 1282 late Sunday a
school teacher located part of the plane
that detached the door plug in their
backyard we're going to go pick that up
uh and make sure that we begin analyzing
it the plug was behind the left wing
it's where the max 9 can have an
optional emergency exit installed Alaska
Airlines didn't need the exit so the
opening had been plugged and sealed
leaving an ordinary window the NTSB says
the plane had reported pressurization
issues three times before the incident
Alaska Airlines kept the aircraft in
service but restricted it from Long
flights over water as a precaution the
maintenance people you know went through
and and did their checks um the pilots
follow followed proper procedures in in
the cockpit and Alaska Airlines was
comfortable uh with this air with this
aircraft flying the plane was just a few
months old leading to speculation about
a potential manufacturing defect as the
investigation continues one key piece of
evidence is missing the cockpit voice
recorder automatically erased because it
wasn't recovered within 2 hours of the
incident the NTSB wants rules changed to
require 25 hours of data preserved in
all new aircraft as a precaution all 171
max9 aircraft in service in the United
States remain grounded leaving hundreds
of flights canceled and thousands of
Travelers scrambling to adjust their
plans
meanwhile shares in Airplane maker
Boeing are down sharply as the incident
delivers yet another blow to the
company's reputation Jackson prosco
Global News Arlington Virginia the
Manitoba government is promising $12
million to improve a highway
intersection where 17 people died last
summer their minius was hit by a
semi-trailer on the Trans Canada Highway
near carbury today's report is not an
investigation into that crash itself but
does propose changes to the intersection
that is known to be dangerous Marne
blunt is in Dolphin that's home to most
of the victims
Marne Donna this community has been
forever changed ever since a bus
carrying 25 passengers left here 6
months ago it was headed to a casino
near carbury when it collided with a
semi on Highway One killing 17 people
and now a new report from The Province
aims to ensure the tragedy like this
will never happen again this is a
difficult topic for all of us but more
so for the family members of those we
lost in this terrible tragedy and of
course for the survivors The Province
briefing family members of victims and
survivors before releasing the report
Monday many of the short-term safety
enhancements have already been put in
place including additional signage
flashing lights and refurbishing the
rumble strips there are also plans for
review on speed and speed compliance the
trucks of the report the medium-term
options which include three Alternatives
including a median widening a roundabout
or a reduced conflict intersection which
forces drivers to turn right and do a
U-turn when trying to go through the
intersection one of those three options
will be selected through a public
consultation process in about 6 months
it's an estimated $12 million project
with construction planned for 2025 and a
target of being complete by Fall 2026
the longer term option being considered
an interchange which would take more
than 25 years Adrien zura's mother
Claudia died in the crash she says she
can't go near the intersection but was
pleased to hear the plans changes have
to come and I think what they brought
forward today I'm I'm happy with it it
does give me some peace as for the
investigation into the crash Manitoba
RCMP say it's still ongoing on Monday
officers wouldn't say whether or not
criminal charges have been ruled out but
did say they have not yet been able to
speak to the driver who was injured in
the crash Donna all right Marne blunt in
Dolphin Manitoba thanks police in New
York state have identified the Montreal
woman killed in a bus crash in Lake
George New York she is 74-year-old Jean
elzani Jordan col 11 others were injured
when the tour bus crashed while on route
from Montreal to New York City on Friday
one person is in critical condition
Global Affairs Canada says it's
providing Consular help to the victims
family it is not yet clear what caused
the crash Israel's Siege on Gaza has
entered its fourth month and reached a
grim Milestone gaza's Health Ministry
run by Hamas says the number of people
killed in Gaza since October 7th has now
topped
23,000 that's about 1% of gaza's total
population The American Secretary of
State is back in Israel tonight Anthony
blinkin is meeting face Toof face with
government officials after weeks of us
pressure to reduce the number of
civilians being killed the Israeli
military claims it is now entering a new
less intense phase of its invasion of
Gaza as Redmond Shannon reports the
reported death of an elite Hezbollah
commander in southern Lebanon is stoking
peers of a widening conflict from Jordan
and kater on Sunday onto Abu Dhabi
Monday morning for US Secretary of State
Anthony blinkin to meet United Arab
Emirates president Al
Nan then to Saudi Arabia to meet Crown
Prince Muhammad bin Salman everywhere I
went I found leaders who are determined
to prevent the conflict that we're
facing now from spreading it has spread
Beyond Gaza and Israel to air strikes
killings and skirmishes in the West Bank
Syria Iraq the Red Sea and Lebanon on
Monday an air strike in Lebanon
reportedly killed Hezbollah Commander
wisam Al tail a week after the killing
of the h Mass Deputy leader there too
Israel has not commented but is believed
to be behind Monday's air strike regard
to to Lebanon it's clearly not in the
interest of anyone Israel Lebanon
Hezbollah for that matter uh to see this
uh to see this escalate Iran is thought
to fund Hezbollah and
Hamas it's foreign Ministry calling us
support for Israel a root cause of the
crisis the King of Jordan more measured
in his criticism of Israel how can
indiscriminate aggression and shelling
bring
peace how can they guarantee security
when they build on hatred inside Gaza
the threat of air strikes sit alongside
a growing humanitarian
crisis despite the destruction of
Israel's military campaign rocket fire
from Gaza continues to the Iron Dome
lighting up the sky in Israel as blinkin
arrives to deescalate a war that shows
little sign of slowing down Redmond
Channon Global News
London it's been four years since the
Iranian military shot down Ukraine
Airlines flight 752 killing all 176
people on board including 55 Canadians
Iran admitted the plane was shot down by
unit of the Islamic revolutionary guard
which fired two surface-to-air missiles
the the families of those who died are
still grieving today memorials took
place around the world including in
Ontario to honor the victims we will
continue our work including continuing
to look for ways to responsibly list the
irgc as a terrorist
organization prime minister Justin tro
says Iran must be held accountable as
[__] mosah reports the victim's
families say they've been the subject of
intimidation and harassment as they call
for justice this is Sufi this is me and
this is Sahan it's been four years since
vahid Emami lost four family members
including his wife and
daughter I miss her all of them killed
in the Downing of Ukraine International
Airlines flight
752 Sophie would have turned nine this
year I'm never going to see how she
grow and what she going to look like
compounding the loss Sophie's
grandmother in Iran was recently
arrested they just took her and beat her
and uh put her in jail Manz zov's
apparent crime attending the funeral of
army teovan a 16-year-old who died weeks
after she was allegedly shoved by Iran's
morality police activists say for not
wearing a hijab I'm angry I'm mad
because
uh I'm here and uh uh I think I can do
nothing I'm far away from them we want
to get the truth out of Iran Iran could
soon be held accountable for the
shooting down of flight
ps752 Canada Sweden Ukraine and the UK
have taken Iran to the international
court of justice in the ha Iran's
Behavior so far in going through these
steps has been absolutely faral Ralph
Goodale Canada's special adviser on
flight 752 announcing Monday the the
four countries have also filed
proceedings against Iran at the
international civil aviation
organization will be pursuing uh Iran in
two different forums under two different
International treaties the intimidation
tactics and harassment taking place
Goodale says is unacceptable this is one
of the dimensions of this case that is
very troubling it is foreign
interference we will keep fighting if
Canada can't succeed in its efforts
vahid amomi says he'll do whatever it
takes to seek Justice including going to
Iran maybe they put me in jail or beat
me or whatever but I have nothing to
lose Nar MOSI Global News
Vancouver it could be a multi-billion
dollar deal for a small Canadian Town
coming up will Honda bring its electric
vehicle Ambitions to
Ontario
[Applause]
Americans are cleaning up from their
first major snowstorm of
2024 which blanketed the Northeast over
the weekend and they're preparing for
what's coming widespread rain is
forecast for tomorrow night that could
trigger flash floods and a separate
storm system is moving North through the
Midwest some states could get up to 30
cmers of snow by
Tuesday that same system will move
through southern Ontario and Quebec
tomorrow it could bring up to 30 cm of
snow there heavy snow is also falling
across parts of BC drivers are being
warned to stay clear of several major
highways Environment Canada has issued
weather warnings watches or statements
in nearly every Province today it's
almost like it's winter welcome
2024 Honda is reportedly considering
Canada for its next multi-billion dollar
electric vehicle plant government
sources say talks will be happening with
Honda this week about the potential deal
Canada plans to end the the sale of gas
powerered passenger vehicles by
2035 this new plant would likely be a
key production hub for Honda Abigail
Bean reports on what the deal could mean
for
Canada just the idea that Honda May
invest1 18.5 billion for an electric
vehicle plant in this small Ontario Town
has people buzzing all I can say if
Honda is watching this there's no better
place than new to come Sith we we've
shown it to you we've proven it to you
and we'd like to do it again mayor
Richard norcros says Honda's two
assembly plants and spin-off industries
make it the biggest employer in town the
company has committed to selling only
EVS in North America by 2040 and
Japanese media reports the automaker has
its eye on Canada for a major investment
to do so a government Source tells
global news federal departments
including the prime minister's office
have a meeting with Honda this week but
no one is confirming a deal just yet in
a statement Honda Canada says it's
currently focused on its EV Hub in Ohio
but in order to achieve the 2040 Target
we are considering various options to
increase local production capacity I
think we're very well positioned to be
on a short list the automotive parts
manufacturers Association believes
Canada can support the resources and
labor force needed and points to Honda's
nearly 40 years in Ontario we like to
say look never walk past an old friend
to greet a new one you know this is a
not just an old friend you know this is
the official uh sponsor of the Toronto
Blue Jays they're part of the Canadian
fabric while former Toyota executive
Greg mue thinks it will be an uphill
battle to secure the deal Canada will be
in deep to try to uh to lure this but
the reality at the end of the day Canada
is not the major Market the US is the
major Market Ottawa has already
committed nearly 30 billion dollars in
subsidies for stellantis and
Volkswagen's two new Ontario battery
plants the big question for a potential
Honda deal will there be more money
Abigail bman Global News Ottawa Apple
has started issuing payments in a
long-running class action lawsuit over
claims it deliberately slowed down older
iPhone models in 2017 the settlement
applies to American customers and is
worth roughly $500 million us payments
work out to about $92 per claim Apple
originally denied any wrongdoing but
later admitted it did intentionally slow
down some iPhone models as they aged to
convince users to buy new iPhones a
hearing to approve a similar settlement
in Canada will be held later this month
lunar Landing ahead how new competitors
are entering the Space
[Music]
Race 5 4 3 we have
ignition and liftoff of the it's going
to the moon at least that's the plan the
first US lunar lander in more than 50
years launched just fine but then
encountered a problem the spacecraft
designed by a Pittsburgh based Aerospace
company is attempting to be the first
private lunar lander if it can actually
land Eric senson explains and liftoff of
the first United launch Alliance Vulcan
rocket get used to this missions to the
moon coming Fast and Furious setbacks
notwithstanding the first launch of a
private moonlander astrobotics paragan
had a smooth start everything looking
good but there was a glitch astrobotic
says a failure within the propulsion
system is causing a critical loss of
propellant still that will not stop the
onslaught of lunar missions including
the first American soft moon landing
since the Apollo 17 Mission when the
last of 12 men walked on the moon 51
years ago scientists United States
around the world have been dying to get
back to the surface of the Moon this is
going to be our first chance to go back
and really make those measurements that
really touch the surface and see what's
really there the Paragon spacecraft on
route to the moon was to orbit the Earth
and the Moon Over several weeks and
finally touch down next next month now
the mission is prioritizing the science
that it can capture but it's only the
first private moon mission this year
intuitive machines Nova c will launch in
February aboard a SpaceX rocket taking a
more direct path to the moon and a third
company fireflies Blue Ghost Lander will
launch later this year they're all
supported by NASA NASA can absorb the
cost of failures by private companies in
return for payload Transportation NASA
is looking to build these uh
Partnerships with industry to help
launch uh the private space industry
competition is fierce to harness the
scientific and Commercial potential of
the Moon China brought back lunar
samples in 20120 India executed a soft
Landing just last year and Russia plans
to set up a moon base in the next decade
Canada is part of NASA's emis mission
that could see Canadian Jeremy Hansen
orbit the Moon as early as this November
the number of countries and companies
entering the space race is only growing
I do see a kind of a momentum that's
built and uh of course now we have
several uh private space companies that
want to be a part of that and no single
setback will slow down a new era in
exploring the moon and Beyond Eric
Sorenson Global News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Monday I'm Donna FZ and tonight's
your candidate is the Rose blanch
lighthouse in Rose blanch Harbor Lau New
Finland and Labrador thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]